- [Narrator] This is Elsie.
She's a Komodo dragon...
The largest species of
lizard on Earth today.
(gentle music)
Females like Elsie can
grow to be 6 feet long
and males are known to
reach 10 feet and weigh over
200 pounds.
They are fierce hunters and
can incapacitate large prey
like deer, water buffalo,
and on rare occasions,
human beings.
Its bacterial-laced
saliva often causes fatal
blood poisoning within 24 hours.
The Komodo dragon can consume
up to 80% of its body weight
in a single feeding.
Native to five Indonesian islands,
Komodo dragons are territorial
and spend much of their
time alone.
These fearsome predators
face numerous threats.
Earthquakes, volcanic
activity, habitat loss,
and illegal poaching have
reduced the wild populations
to only a few thousand.
This is the Komodo dragon.
(gentle music)